Labor's mission of an economy built by
the many for the many and friends what a
contrast it is with that extreme
trickle-down Tory budget last week an
economy built by the few for the few and
friends if you've seen the news this
morning it's clear the Tories May
believe in the markets but even the
markets no longer believe in the Tories
and friends and friends we owe it to the
country to defeat this lot at the next
general election
now friends we meet here amidst three
emergencies an energy bills crisis
facing millions of families and energy
security crisis and the climate crisis
I say to you these emergencies demand
the boldest of leadership these
emergencies demand an energy policy for
the people and for the planet I say
these emergencies demand a labor
government
let's start let's start with bills Labor
led the way in January with the call for
a windfall tax Labor led the way in
August with a call for an energy price
freeze now now Liz truss she says she
won't have a windfall tax because she
says it's a labor idea
she said that you know I think for the
first time in recorded history Liz truss
has got something right the the windfall
tax is a labor idea standing up to the
big vested interest so we can help the
people of Britain in that moment of need
an energy policy for the people and the
planet labor ideas labor values labor
principles
thank you
now you know you know the crises we face
that I talked about might seem different
but they all come from One Source the
climate and nature crisis is caused by
the burning of fossil fuels the energy
bills crisis is caused by the fact that
we're exposed to the roller coaster of
fossil fuel prices
and the crisis of energy security comes
from the global Scramble for gas
so all these crises have the same
ultimate cause our dependence on fossil
fuels
and all of them and all of them have the
same solution low-cost homegrown zero
carbon power for our country
you know you know today the cost of
solar and wind energy is nine times less
than that of gas this is the defining
truth of our age this is the undeniable
truth of our age it is cheaper to save
the planet than it is to destroy it
that that's why I am I'm so proud to say
a labor government will make Britain the
first country in the world to set and
achieve the target of zero carbon power
by 2030.
93 billion pounds of energy bills it
will make Britain a clean energy
superpower and friends we will do it by
sweeping away that Tory Dogma that is
holding our country back it is within
our grasp let's hear it for doubling
onshore wind trebling solar power
quadrupling offshore wind tidal Power
Nuclear hydrogen power and all
underpinned by the best investment we
can make 60 billion pounds over a decade
to insulate 19 million cold drafty homes
saving a thousand pounds off bills
touching carbon emissions mobilizing
thousands of businesses and yes friends
led by our brilliant labor local
authorities up and down Britain that's
what I mean by an energy policy for the
people and the planet
thank you
thank you
thank
you
now you know what are the Tories offer
instead they tell us after 12 years in
power
after after four Tory Prime Ministers
after all their promises they say and
I'm not making this up the energy system
is broken
that's what they say friends who broke
the Energy System they did who banned
onshore wind they did who said cut the
green crap and drove up bills they did
who slashed home insulation
very good who deregulated the energy
Market who directed yeah yeah I've got
more I've even got more who deregulated
the energy market and let 32 companies
go bust
friends I've got an idea if we want to
mend the broken Energy System let's
start by getting rid of the Tories who
broke it
thank you
and
and guess what and guess what with these
Tories fracking is back the tour is band
fracking in 2019 because they said it
was dangerous now they've moved the goal
posts under the Tories and I'm not
making this up either moderate
earthquakes are just fine
that that's their position
so I say to you let every Tory MP and
candidate be asked where do you stand on
dangerous expensive fracking where do
you stand on breaking your Manifesto
promises friends let them try and sell
let them try and sell their Charter for
earthquakes to the people of Lancashire
Yorkshire the Midlands and communities
across the country we will hold them to
account on behalf of the British people
and and who do they say who who do they
say who do they choose who do they
choose to be solemnly entrusted to look
after the future of our planet Jacob
Reese MOG
19th century MOG a a man who says a man
who says we should extract every last
drop he says of oil and gas even though
it would mean three degrees of global
warming a man who says and I'm quoting
him trying to forecast the climate is
unrealistic the cost is probably
unaffordable
friends let's call it what it is this is
dangerous climate denial
if you want an energy policy for the
1820s Jacob Reese MOG is your man if you
want one for the 2020s we need a labor
government friend
and let me let me tell you this because
I listen carefully to the debate our
plans are not just about Transforming
Our Energy System they're about
Transforming Our economy too you know
there's a global race on for the jobs of
the future and Britain under the Tories
is losing it
uh let me tell you about itm power in
Sheffield they're one of the world
leaders in the hydrogen industry they
were looking at the UK for a new Factory
but seeing the lack of support on offer
from the British government they now
plan to go overseas I say it must and it
will be different under a labor
government it's time to invest in
Britain again friends
that's that's why Rachel Reeves and I
are today announcing a new institution
that will take back control of Britain's
economic Destiny government as partner
investor and yes shareholder working
with business a new National wealth fund
for Britain
and let me tell you what that's going to
do it's gonna lead the world in hydrogen
lead the world in the EV Revolution from
the Northeast to the West Midlands leave
the world in green steel from Port
Talbert to scunthorpe lead the world in
decarbonizing Industry from here on
merseyside to grangemouth leave the
world in jobs from the southwest to
Scotland in offshore wind good jobs at
good wages with strong trade Unions
that's what I mean by a green new deal
that's what I mean by an energy policy
for the people and the planet
and Friends it cuts to a deeper truth
and I heard this so clearly in the
debate the goal of the next Labor
government can't just be to Tinker round
the edges the hour is too late the
moment is too serious the next Labor
government will deliver fundamental
reform to the institutions of our
economy so we have an economy built by
working people for working people
friends as it says on the party card
power wealth and opportunity in the
hands of the many not the few
so let me tell you here is the election
Choice lower energy bills with labor
higher bills under the Tories energy
security with labor energy insecurity
under the Tories millions of green jobs
with labor opportunities squandered
under the Tories leading the world again
in tackling the climate crisis with
labor climate delay and denial under the
Tories friends these are the stakes
don't let anyone tell you all parties
are the same don't let anyone tell you
politics doesn't matter don't let anyone
tell you nothing will change whoever you
vote for this is our mission this is our
chance let's protect the people and the
planet let's rise to this moment let's
lead and together let's transform our
country thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you very much
thank you
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much Ed
um we now have time for just a few more
speakers was there somebody from
Scotland
okay I can see that one hand up you come
now please very quickly and someone from
the south east
okay with you I think on the end of the
row there yes you who is just standing
up right
so that's two of you I've called so far
is that right just check
you're the person from Scotland
the other person that was there and then
you need to come to the desk before you
can
and there was
a youth
can I just check where else we've got so
is there anybody from the south west
that was indicating
you were from the south west okay you
get to come and I I think this is going
to be it for now but please go ahead
delegate
thank you chair and thank you conference
I'm proud to represent Glasgow Kelvin
CLP and the City of Glasgow
thank you
[Applause]
conference Glasgow was recently dubbed
in the press to strike city which I can
assure you was thoroughly taken as a
compliment
I urge you to support comp support
compensate motion one and honor the work
that our comrades and the trade unions
and communities that support them have
been doing in recent months when labor
members and representatives get on a
picket we acknowledge our party's
history and reassure the public that we
retain our core values
as it's delicate from Sutton and shame
CLP
um rightly acknowledged earlier on the
shadow cabinet at Westminster are the
exception and not the rule
labor representatives in leadership in
Scotland and Wales have been Lively and
proudly standing on the picket lines
with striking workers across unions and
industries
it's my great pleasure to support the
motion that was moved by unite in CWU
though I would have enjoyed the
opportunity to take part in the
composition last night Glasgow Kelvin
CLP submitted a motion regarding strike
action that was remitted by the CAC on
the basis that it referenced Shadow
cabinet attendance on packets and this
should be considered quote an
organizational matter unquote
the only reference to organization that
I want to hear from our most senior
elected representatives is organized and
to help workers and their unions when
Victory to all striking workers thank
you
thank you
hi conference I'm Marie Tidwell I'm
Community Union delegate conference when
I was last on this stage in Liverpool
four years ago I had my six week old
baby in a sling
now my little girl is at school and I'm
standing here as the labor parliamentary
candidate for peniston and stocksbridge
the place where I grew up and call home
when I was a child my dad a counselor
for doddeth was chair of Barnsley
passenger transport South Yorkshire had
a world-class bus service thanks to our
labor County Council
leaving you then as we know now that
buses are for the people
Labor's Fair fares allowed you to travel
from one side of our constituency to
another cheaply and reliably
in penicillin stocksbridge buses are a
Lifeline which connects our families and
our communities but the conservatives
just don't get it
we were promised a london-style
transport system what we got was a
Bargain Basement budget
getting half what they promised worse
still South Yorkshire didn't receive a
single penny of bus Improvement funding
a kick in the teeth for local people who
feel like the current Tory MP has only
and I quote put her head above the
parapet when it is too late and it is
too late we are already seeing Services
being seriously reduced like our SLL one
super tram service link and the number
57 only on Saturday I spoke to a mum in
utterbridge who was worried about these
cuts to services and how her 14 year old
son was going to get to school
labor will put people back in control of
our buses and at the center of our bus
services
making them
making them Greener fairer and more
reliable so that young and old in our
rural areas our towns and Villages
across peniston and stocksbridge are not
isolated so that children can get to
school so that our shift workers can do
the jobs we rely on them to do for fair
fares and safely
every single one of us has the right to
use buses to travel to work and see our
families and friends without using a car
public transport is fundamental to
achieving social justice and tackling
the climate emergency
as the MP for peniston and stocksbridge
I will help secure the public transport
system that our communities deserve and
that our planet desperately needs thank
you
[Applause]
much
so it's now my great pleasure to invite
Jonathan Reynolds MP Shadow Secretary of
State for business I'm sorry it's not my
great pleasure to do that yet I'm going
to have another speaker apology
Okay cool so um hi I'm Isabel Saxby
first time delegate and I'm representing
West Devon and torridge yeah thank you
um so I'm representing West Devon and
torridge
um so West Devon is Rife with second
homes terrible transport links and
Rising costs and it's not a surprise
considering rmp is Jeffrey Cox so I want
to know how people are expected to
compete with millionaires TUC found that
over a fifth of workers in the southwest
are earning under the real living wage
in West Devon we have the lowest pay in
Devon and the third worst pay in the UK
torridge as the second highest
proportion of workers earning below the
living wage out of all local authorities
in Britain it's the Tories that have
caused this the rise in child poverty
over the last 12 years empty shelves tax
increases lower pensions pay freezes
benefit cuts and raw sewage spewed into
our rivers and onto our beaches places
like Devon and Cornwall are more than
just holiday destinations for City for
City dwellers they can be hives of
economic activity that offer decent jobs
in advanced engineering and green
technologies as well as our core
Industries in healthcare education and
culture but this all needs proper
investment and attention from a national
government if local workers are to get a
chance at earning a proper living labor
is here for the many and not the few so
please support the motion five on a 15
pound pay because it's essential but
thank you so much
I it now really is my great pleasure to
invite Jonathan Reynolds MP Shadow
Secretary of State for business and
Industrial strategy thank you John
conference thank you for the chance to
address you today
we meet at the time when the challenges
facing our country are very grave indeed
when you're worried about how your
communities and your families are going
to get through the months ahead
and I know it's hard to feel optimistic
when things are so tough
but serving in this role has given me
cause for hope
and I know a fresh start with labor can
rebuild this country
I'm thinking of the steel workers I met
in Port Talbot who were ready to make
the green steel customers want
the automotive workers in my hometown of
Sunderland who have the skills to make
the electric cars we need
the scientists I met at Imperial College
you have the ideas to solve some of our
greatest challenges
we've got some brilliant people in this
country
but what we don't have is a government
committed to a domestic steel sector or
to building the battery factories we
need
we don't have a government who values
the collaboration of scientists across
Europe
we simply don't have a government that's
on people's side and that is what we
must change
there was a time when the Tories
believed they were the party of business
now they're just in the business of
parties
[Applause]
12 years
12 years of misrule they have failed
British business on their watch business
investment is the lowest in the G7
economic growth is said to be the lowest
in the G7 we've had the worst squeeze to
real wages of any country in the G7 and
don't just take my word for it let's ask
them they admit it the new Chancellor
said they have presided over a vicious
cycle of stagnation
the new prime minister has said our
public services are in a state
frankly when the Tories find out who's
been running this country for the last
12 years they are going to be furious
and that is now that is now the Big
Choice in British politics everyone
agrees the last 12 years have been awful
the differences we choose to look to the
Future while the conservatives are
dusting off the failed policies of the
past
in the face of an energy crisis a
business investment crisis a climate
crisis
who have they picked to meet these
challenges
as Ed said it's Jacob Reese mug
one newspaper said he'd be better suited
to running a museum than the business
department
frankly conference museums are far too
important for that
another tories
the Tories want to claim they've got the
answers to the problems they've created
and it's higher Bankers bonuses
it's cuts to corporation tax
deregulation
picking fights in divisive politics and
it won't work
George Osbourne's cuts to corporations
act didn't increase business investment
and we all know what deregulation is
called for
cuts to working people's rights
cut to environmental standards so more
sewage ends up in the rivers
a race to the bottom which good
businesses and working people never win
now I agree with the Tories on one thing
the last 12 years have been a disaster
but while they want to double down on
their mistakes we've got a real plan to
make it better
conference I'm pleased to announce today
that we are launching Labor's industrial
strategy and it's a real industrial
strategy with ambition and the means to
achieve it
our industrial strategy will deliver
clean Power by 2030. taking the action
lead on the climate emergency and
keeping good jobs in Britain for decades
to come
we'll harness
we'll harness data for the public good
ensuring isn't just held by corporate
Gatekeepers but used to benefit us all
and will Buster our national resilience
ensuring our supply chains and working
people are never again left so exposed
to Global shocks
and finally will value the care sector
for what it is an essential part of our
economy ending the job in security too
often associated with this vital work
we've got the policies to make it happen
Fair pay agreements will be to the next
Labor government what the national
minimum wage was to the last one
and Conference
I pledge to you now they will never ever
be a scandal like piano furries under a
labor government
because
because of proper industrial strategy
our new deal for working people are a
form of business rates our targets for
greater spending on research and science
these provide the real alternative the
country needs labor knows that's how you
grow the economy not on the backs of
working people or rewarding bad practice
but through vision and Leadership and
real partnership to make economic
success a reality
no one can deny
Britain faces some significant
challenges but rather than shrink from
these challenges the role of government
is to meet them head on
many of you lived through the 1980s when
Tory governments left people on their
own in the face of massive industrial
change
we cannot and we must not allow this
generation of Tories to do the same in
response to the challenges we face today
good work good wages a fairer Greener
future that is what we can deliver
and I ask for your support of every one
of you to make it happen thank you
conference
[Applause]
thank you very much Jonathan
we will conclude the better jobs better
work debate and take the votes after our
next speaker it gives me great pleasure
to introduce our shadow Chancellor
Rachel roots
thank you
thank you thank you conference
it's it's a privilege to stand here
as your Shadow Chancellor
under Kia stalma's leadership
but I know what the responsibility this
is too
we are facing a national emergency
Energy prices up
the cost of the weekly food shop up
people's wages not keeping up
on Friday the chancellor had an
opportunity to set out a serious
response to the cost of living crisis
and he failed
what did we get instead
a tax cut for the wealthiest one percent
increased Bankers bonuses
and more than 50 billion pounds piled
onto the national debt every single year
they didn't just break their own fiscal
rules for the tenth time in 12 years
in one go they borrowed more than in any
single budget since 1972.
with inflation already high
and interest rates are already Rising
the message from financial markets was
clear on Friday
and this morning
that message is even more Stark
Sterling is down
that means higher prices as the costs of
imports rise
the cost of government borrowing is up
that means more taxpayers money will go
into paying the interest on our
government debt
and in turn that means the cost of
borrowing for working people will now go
up to
with higher mortgage repayments for
families
and all for what
not to invest in the industries of the
future
not for our NHS and not for our schools
but for tax cuts for the wealthiest a
return to trickle-down economics an idea
that has been tried has been tested and
has failed
why should my constituents in Leeds West
why should people in merseyside pay for
tax cuts for those who are already the
wealthiest
it's not what anyone voted for it's
putting our economy in danger and
Conference labor will fight at every
step of the way
conference
let me tell you what I believe
I believe that hard work should be met
with their reward
I believe that strong public services
are the backbone of any decent Society
I believe that inequality divides and
holds us back as a country
conference I believe that the task of
building a fairer Society is a moral
responsibility and more than that it is
the route to a stronger economy
the truth is at the heart of Labor's
plans for growth and today I want to
tell you why
last April
on a Cold Spring evening I knocked on
the door of a constituent
when I reached out to shake her hands it
was purple
and freezing cold
already back then she was afraid to put
the heating on
struggling to get by on the small
pension that she had built up through a
lifetime of work
as energy bills and inflation rise even
higher
I often think of her
conference that is the Stark reality
facing people all around our country
today
and while the Prime Minister spent
months denying the need for action on
Energy prices
labor was calling for a freeze on the
energy price cap labor was calling for
an end to the indefensible premium paid
by families with prepayment leaders
and crucially labor was calling for a
windfall tax on the unimaginable profits
being made by the oil and gas companies
because a proper windfall tax would mean
that working people didn't have to foot
the bill
but the prime minister is content to let
energy Giants pocket the cash and leave
your children
and your grandchildren to pick up the
tab
under these Tories those with the
broadest shoulders
carry the lightest load
and not by accident
but by choice
conference it is time for a government
that is on your side and that government
is a labor government
the effects of Putin's War have
reverberated around the world
and we will not waver in our support for
Ukraine
the causes of this crisis are global but
our unique exposure to Rising Energy
prices
is a result of the choices of
conservative governments
in action on insulating homes in action
on renewable and nuclear energy and the
sheer irresponsibility of closing our
gas storage facilities
we are feeling the consequences
of a 12-year Tory experiment in
unilateral energy disarmament
[Applause]
lifting the ban on fracking
conference fracking is dangerous it is
bad for the planet it won't even reduce
our bills and with labor it will not
happen
here is our alternative
our green Prosperity plan
to provide the only sustainable solution
to the energy crisis
to free ourselves from dependence on
Russia to invest in solar in wind in
Tidal in hydrogen and in nuclear power
and to pass on to our children a fairer
and a Greener country
this is a moral responsibility
and it's an economic necessity
on climate change the costs of inaction
today will mean far greater costs
tomorrow
I refuse to leave our children to pick
up the pieces of our failure
conference I will be a responsible
Chancellor I will be Britain's first
green Chancellor
Ed miliband has just set out how the
next Labor government will cut to energy
bills for good
by generating all of our electricity
from clean sources by 2030.
but our green Prosperity plan is about
something else too
it is about economic growth
because British businesses are falling
behind in the global race for new
Industries
and that matters
it matters that the largest offshore
wind farm in Scotland has its blades
made not in Scotland but thousands of
miles away
it matters that the rest of Europe is
powering ahead with electric battery
factories and we are stuck in the slow
lane
it matters that Germany France and the
US are making the running with green
hydrogen but we are not
we have the ability
but we want the jobs here we want the
factories here and we want British
businesses to take the lead
here here is the deal
the next Labor governments will create a
national wealth fund
so that when we invest in new Industries
in partnership with business
the British people will own a share of
that wealth
and the taxpayer will get a return on
that investment
wealth flowing from jobs in electric
battery factories in the West Midlands
the Northeast the Northwest and the
Southwest
offshore wind driving investment in our
ports from the Humber to Southampton
East Anglia to Belfast
clean steel with jobs in Rotherham
Sheffield scunthorpe Cardiff and Port
Talbot
and carbon capture in our Industrial
heartlands in grangemouth and in South
Wales in Humber and in t side and here
in merseyside too
because conference when I say I want to
buy make and sell more in Britain I mean
it
what you will see in your town in your
city with labor
is a site that we have not seen often
enough in our country
cranes going up
shovels in the grounds the sounds and
the sights of the future arriving
secure skilled jobs for plumbers
electricians and joiners for designers
scientists and engineers
wealth that will flow back into your
community and onto your High Street
wealth that the British people will own
a stake in wealth that is invested in
our country's future that is a real plan
for climate that is a real plan for
growth and Conference that is a real
plan for leveling up
thank you
a zero carbon economy made right here
made in Britain it is time for a
government that is on your side and that
government is a labor government
s
six different plans for growth in 12
years each announced with great fanfare
each making no difference a library of
failure
conference they've had 12 years
have they got growth up no have they got
inflation down no have they got child
poverty down no have they got the NHS
waiting lists down no and have they even
got the debts and the deficit down no
conference it's 12 years of failure
and now
they have replaced leveling up
with trickle down
an economic philosophy inadequate to a
modern world and a moral philosophy
inadequate to a decent Society
trickle-down economics is a very simple
idea
if we just slash taxes and regulation we
will unleash investment and growth
that how wealth is shared doesn't really
matter
false gaps between people and places no
importance workers rights consumer
protection strong Public Services all
worth sacrificing
that wealth is just created by a few
people a few businesses
it's why at the same time that ministers
lecture low paid workers about showing
restraints that they can't restrain
themselves from removing the cap on
Bankers bonuses
I dare any Tory MP to tell a nurse or a
care worker to their face that what our
country needs right now is bigger
bonuses for bankers
true trickle down is a very simple idea
and the very wrong one
not just wrong because it isn't fair Run
2 conference because it doesn't work
trickle down is wrong because how wealth
is shared does matter to growth
High inequality strangles the spending
power of working people
it piles its social costs onto our
Public Services
suffocates potential
trickle-down is wrong because in a
turbulent World businesses need
government as a partner
trickle down is wrong because strong
institutions and robust public finances
provide the foundations for a strong
economy
and trickle-down is wrong conference
because a strong economy needs strong
Public Services we will defeat the
failed ideas of the past with the focus
the ambition and the ideas for the
future
conference
here's the truth
wealth doesn't trickle from the top down
it comes from the bottom up and the
middle out from the talent and the
efforts of tens of millions of ordinary
people and from thousands of businesses
our economy needs the most productive
most high-tech businesses to thrive in
Britain
and we all rely on what I call the
everyday economy
on transport workers and delivery
drivers
on supermarkets and Retail workers are
NHS and care workers
don't let anyone tell you that they are
not wealth creators too
they
they are key to our security as a
society
and yet too many of them are amongst the
most insecure
overworked
underpaid
undervalued
the Tories that trickle down ideology
has nothing to offer them Beyond longer
hours lower pay and less respect
earlier this year I met a family in
Worthing
a Mum and Dad working five jobs between
them struggling to make ends meet
constantly juggling work and child care
as a family they only got half a day a
week together they felt that any hope of
buying their own home had evaporated
good people working hard
do you know what the mum said to me
she said
you just wonder if you're doing
something wrong
conference something is profoundly wrong
and let's be clear Liz Truss
we've not fallen behind our neighbors on
growth on productivity or on pay
because British workers lack graft
it's not working people that are the
problem conference is this government
that is the problem
thank you
I'll tell you what a growing economy
needs Rising wages so that money flows
back into vibrant High streets parents
with the time to thrive at work and
spend time with their children families
with enough savings to weather a storm
and people feeling the confidence to
take risks to change career to learn new
skills or start a business
so
with labor
there'll be no bonfire of workers rights
as the Tories intend
as Angela Rayner announced
we will introduce a new deal for working
people with strengthened rights fit for
the times we are in
and that's not all
on day one as Chancellor
I will write to the local pay commission
with a simple instruction
that the minimum wage will be set at a
level that reflects the Real Cost of
Living
the last Labor government delivered
Britain's first ever national minimum
wage the next Labor government will
introduce a genuine living wage
that's how we will give working people
security and that's how we will grow our
economy too
it's time for a government that is on
your side and that government is a labor
government
here's another thing about growing a
21st century economy
it's no longer enough if it ever was for
government to Simply get out of the way
challenges of global instability of
pandana pandemics wars and climate
crisis
demand that government work in
partnership with business
if I were Chancellor right now I would
bring together a National Economic
Council that will bring together
industry and trade unions so working
people and businesses were at the heart
of economic decision making
I have been privileged in this job
to visit businesses across our country
from Rolls-Royce in Derby pioneering
Research into carbon neutral Aviation
to Oxford nanopore leading work on DNA
and RNA sequencing
right through to local businesses like
Castleton Mill
once a key part of West yorkshire's
textiles industry and now a
collaborative space for Freelancers
remote workers and startups
the world is changing fast
but the British capacity
the Enterprise for Innovation and for
hard work remains undimmed
when I talk to business they don't tell
me that their number one priority is
corporation tax
they tell me about the need for properly
targeted investment allowances the need
for workers equipped with the right
skills
the need for certainty and a sense of
direction from government
and yes the need for a sensible working
relationship with our European Neighbors
so we will take those issues head on
starting with the biggest tax problem
facing British businesses
our unfair outdated system of business
rates punishes High Street businesses to
the advantage of online Giants
so labor will level the playing field
we will abolish business rates and
replace them with a fairer system fit
for the 21st century
that new system
that new system will mean that
businesses will get revaluation
discounts straight away rather than
waiting for years for their money back
and here's more
today Jonathan Reynolds launched our
modern industrial strategy that
recognizes the importance of businesses
at the high-tech Frontier and of our
everyday economy
it sets out a mission to make our
economy more secure
we will use all powers at government
disposal to buy make and sell more here
in Britain
we will make Britain the best place to
start and grow a business Guided by the
work of our startup review headed by
Lord Jim O'Neill
and we will give our Nations and regions
Mayors and local leaders right across
Britain the tools to shape their own
future
in labor-run Wales under Mark Drakeford
in our city regions and all around the
country we are seeing the difference
that labor can make in power and Steve
Rotherham thank you for the leadership
that you show here in merseyside
and Conference
if you're remotely serious about growth
then you've got to make brexit work
our Agriculture and our food Industries
rely on trade right across Europe but we
have a deal that doesn't even include a
Veterinary agreement
we are pioneers in Creative Industries
but we have a deal which light ties them
in knots over visas
we are the second largest exporter of
services in the world but we have a deal
that doesn't include the mutual
recognition of professional
qualifications
so we will fix the holes in the
government's Patchwork brexit deal
and instead of picking needless fights
with our largest trading partner we will
work together with our neighbors and our
allies in our national interest
that is Labor's approach proudly
pro-worker and proudly pro-business
supporting Innovation sharing
opportunity Reviving our high streets
conference it is time for a government
that is on your side and that government
is a labor government
I am proud to have started my career as
an economist at the bank of England
it's operational Independence is an
enduring contribution by the last Labor
government to Britain's Financial
stability
growth and social justice must be built
on firm foundations
yet this government
has undermined the bank's Independence
sacked the respected permanent secretary
to the treasury and gagged the office
for Budget responsibility
the chancellor and prime minister
meanwhile resembled two desperate
gamblers in a casino chasing a losing
run
but here's the thing
they're not gambling with their money
they're gambling with yours
they've lost credibility they're losing
confidence they're out of control
and I've said this before conference but
be in no doubt
there can be no return to austerity
it has left our country poorer
our public services at breaking points
and our public finances in tatters
I make this promise to you
labor will not waver in our commitment
to fiscal responsibility
that is why I set out the fiscal rules
for the next Labor government a year ago
every policy that labor announces
and every line in our Manifesto
will be carefully costed and fully
funded
last year I told this conference that I
was more than happy to take on the
Tories when it came to economic
competence because I know we can win
I'm now wondering whether they even plan
to show up for the fights it's
it's becoming clearer by the day labor
is the party of economic responsibility
and the party of social justice
conference it's time for a government
that is on your side and that government
is a labor government
now
we need a growing economy we need a
growing economy to pay for modern
sustainable Public Services
but a growing economy needs strong
Public Services too
this is personal to me
my mum and dad were Primary School
teachers
I'm really proud of that
my sister Ellie and I used to play for
hours in my dad's classroom while he
worked late into the evening
because he wanted the kids that he
taught to have the very best start in
life
this was all in the face of conservative
governments hostile to the very idea of
Public Service
I went to school under those governments
I remember what it was like
this is why I joined this party
and it is why I am here today
strong public services are the
foundation of a strong Society
and Conference
we owe everything to those who work in
our National Health Service
so no
we also know that our health service
today is on its knees
it is a social priority and it is an
economic priority
in the last three years half a million
people have left the labor market
more than half of those due to long-term
illness
so as Kia stama set out a year ago we
will guarantee access to mental health
treatment within a month to anyone who
needs it
here's more
we need strong sustainable public
finances alongside strong sustainable
Public Services
so our priority
is not tax cuts for the wealthiest of
you
curing our public finances
and investing in our Public Services
conference
I can tell you
with a labor government those at the top
will pay their fair share
the 45p top rate of income tax is coming
back
cheers and here's what we'll do with
that money
the next Labor government will double
the number of District nurses qualifying
every year
we will train
more than 5 000 new health visitors
we will create an additional 10 000
nursing and midwife places every year
more than that
we will implement the biggest expansion
of medical school places in British
history
so I believe a number of medical
students so our NHS has the doctors that
it needs
it will fall to us
to fix the damage that the Tories have
done
we have done it before and Conference we
will do it again
know that these are Labor's priorities
strong public services to support people
and grow our economy
A Greener fairer Britain with jobs for
people in Britain Industries owned by
the people of Britain profits shared
with the people of Britain pro-business
and pro-worker for a stronger economy
where you do well
because when you do well Britain does
well
hope and opportunity whoever you are
wherever you live that is Labor's vision
for Britain that is what we are fighting
for let me tell you it's time for a
government that is on your side that
government is a labor government and be
in no doubt conference that government
is on its way
okay
thank you conference
thank you conference
thank you Rachel
so we now have one final speaker so if
you could very quickly make your way
from the fbu also in the darkened area
of the room
um then we will take that final speaker
and while you're making your way I will
just make an announcement
I'm not trying to make you leave the
hall but you do need to know this the
UEFA women's 2022 trophy is at
conference and will be I don't know and
we'll be on display at stand 73 from
four o'clock
[Applause]
is the speaker from the fbu on their way
yes brilliant
and then we are taking the votes so
please make sure if you're leaving you
leave very very quietly but don't leave
I can't wait Steve Wright from the fire
brigade Union uh firstly I would like to
say from the outset The More Union the
fire brigade Union supports striking
workers the Dockers the posties and the
railway workers
and we have been and we always will be
on the picket lines with you and I will
repeat the call that has been made today
will the labor leadership will Kirsten
if he can still hear me join those
picket lines will he join our picket
lines when we move to strike action
I'd like to thank the CWU and unite for
bringing composite one which importantly
calls for public ownership and let's not
be ashamed of calling for public
ownership we are socialists after all
and we wouldn't have firefighters going
to food banks if the current system was
working
the pandemic only Amplified the skewed
power relations in society we must not
go back to the old system we must build
a fairer more equal society that gives
everyone a stake a voice at work and a
hope for a better future
we know that we can never trust the
ruling class and a Tory government but
to protect workers they continue to show
their utter contempt for workers and we
must prepare for their future attacks
workers should and will not pay for this
crisis the labor movement is stating
this loud and clear in this conference
Hall and so should the labor party
there are attacks coming our way to our
Union and we must build our resistance
and our movement to fight them comrade
another threat still lays dormant that
hasn't been mentioned too much today the
climate emergency the industrial issue
for my union and ultimately a class
struggle that we have to